[Music]  before you became a late-night talk-show  host didn't you write some screenplay  that Mick Jagger hired you to write oh  yeah yeah and like you would meet  regularly with Mick Jagger I was on tour  with them for like a couple of months  that to me would be [ __ ] mind-blowing  it was they fly me Istanbul and I go and  meet Mick Jagger and they opened the  door of the suite and he's the first  time I see him he's literally a tiny  little guy busy and I said - oh I didn't  know why I said I went oh you're  adorable guys I heard I was like why did  I say that what fell apart like why have  I never seen Mick Jagger's movies like I  wrote the screenplay I wrote two drafts  of it he's like now it doesn't not like  it and then I got fired and that right  yeah I heard a my again I've never seen  him again no no never again he fired me  but he's nice about it he got his  assistant to do it so it's cool right  now he completed a little awkward moment  [Laughter]